by clicking air products and according  to the interior ministry two men who on  biet of border vehicle rammed the  factory and they were carrying some kind  of bottles of gas in in the Indus  vehicle and there was an explosion and  two people two employees were injured in  that explosion now it's very unclear  what's happening but what they said is  that they found a man who had been  decapitated inside the factory the  person they found an employee so whether  these people brought this person with  them it is very unclear subsequently  they have made already one rest and it's  unclear whether this is an ongoing  situation a very other key fact is that  these men were carrying flags with extra  inscriptions in Arabic obviously a  little early to say whether these are  were armed Islamist or not but it does  appear to be the case that's all I know  for now